my fans are like I've never been
attacked by that many people online
beehive was trippin yet again no beehive
is not a when you put like extra
nests on it the beehive is very serious
about what they want and what they want
to get accomplished in house loving they
are Beyonce
[Music]
just growing up in general went through
a lot of like hard times and people are
always telling me you should be sorry
like say you're sorry you know keep your
mouth shut do this do this and then when
lemonade came out I was going around my
house like just liking her was taboo
because I was trying you know to pass
first rate over every but at the end of
the day you know I like what I like and
you know this loving Beyonce has
inspired me because she has never let me
down
Beyonce doesn't know but she's literally
impacted my life more than she could
ever know she's been in my life since I
was a little girl and she's taught me so
many lessons that my mom my dad and my
family didn't teach me how to be an
independent woman do I pay my own bills
am i sexy but I'm classy and even like
in dark stages where I felt like a lone
or abandoned like Beyonce is like you
have yours me myself and I that's all I
have in the end I can't express it
enough
three two one oh my gosh I wouldn't be
like in the middle of these to be like
okay yes I think you can be a casual fan
of things I can't name all of her music
but I'm still a fan of hers liking
somebody doesn't necessarily make you a
fan so if you support somebody you love
what they do the message that they bring
the empowerment they're about you're of
fan and you would know a lot about that
person you would invest in that person
versus somebody you like you're not
gonna know much about them but if you're
a fan of chocolate cake you might not
know all the ingredients I think it's
possible for us to know everything about
her yeah like a queen bee is always
gonna have secrets
I'm sorry but at the end of the day no
matter what you do whatever you say
you're responsible for your own actions
it's not her job to control what comes
out of other people's mouths and how
they act I think that's like saying oh I
watched a bunch of horror movies and
played a bunch of murder video games let
me go out and murder someone like at the
end of the day you can't blame that
movie you're murdering somebody you know
you know say is I mother should have you
know her influence on someone but an
influence can only take you so far you
know you are who you are and you do what
you do on your own I don't know I have
to disagree because I think when you're
a public figure you have a moral
obligation to stand up for what's right
for the people that are following you
she never has really been like okay fans
don't do this do this because we all
kind of like know like a standard of how
to be have you seen the whole thing with
the wife of the NBA the game oh yeah PR
made a statement telling to be high to
act good because they just went in they
were already they were dragging her like
death threat that's the first time
that's like one of the first time the US
has actually had to speak up we also
live in a time where more people are you
know committing suicide because they're
being bullied on social media I think
she is responsible so we need public
figures to speak up and not allow that
kind of behavior from their fans
[Music]
I personally think he's been abusing
their relationship we don't know how
much they've been through but there's a
time where it comes where you have to
draw the line and communicate what it is
that you are you are not going to put up
with marriage is not easy I've been
married for a couple years and with
jay-z and Beyonce both sharing their
experience they're going through that
and healing their relationship if that
was so powerful as an example to
everybody like not just to cast away
their marriage has something happened
that you would be justified to walk away
from I honor her for not leaving and for
being strong and then voicing her
emotions and her feelings through Lemony
you know she she was very vocal about it
and talked about the journey of it and
how she recovered from it
[Music]
I'm here because um I'm like stuck on
the definition of feminism because a lot
of people misconstrue that to be
whatever they want it to be for
themselves so in general what is it
really I don't think she would make so
many songs about you know like single
ladies pretty hurts like she's not gonna
make this song she make these songs for
women and she doesn't support women the
only reason I'm here is cuz I don't see
her whole life so she could be shady
behind the scenes and we just don't know
about it I don't think that she's doing
it for fame at all I think it's part of
who she is I don't think that um as an
artist I don't think she'd put out
anything that she didn't believe in
she's just about telling people to be
who they are and and do it fiercely I
think when somebody has the amount of
power she has I just expect more since
she has this platform she could use it
to not just help women but help women
that are also transgender she can help
women that are also maybe having body
positivity issues and so just because I
don't think of that kind of thing when I
think of Beyonce I just don't see her as
like incredibly feminist
[Music]
well I know I'm over here but um for me
I think perfection is about authenticity
I don't think that perfection means that
she can do no wrong I just think that
she is perfectly authentic as a woman it
took me a long long time to get to this
point when I was younger like I was
perfect to my eyes and she was that
flawless you know girl but when she came
out with the Beyonce album you know self
title like some of the messages she came
out with like even in a song pretty
hurts like she is not perfect and that's
okay because nobody is perfect and that
just helped me with you know knowing
that I don't have to be perfect either
you know I can still you know strive to
be you know that level of Beyonce but I
don't have to be you know perfect to do
that
[Applause]
hey guys I'm Michael and thank you so
much for watching this episode let us
know what you thought in the comments
below but make sure you really let us
know what you won't really let us know
what you thought I know there are
lurkers on there who just watch the
video and don't say anything but you
guys are holding back amazing insights
that the rest of us could learn from
we'll see you next time